I'm B.F. Skinner, and Hippocrates and Mendel have done some nice work, but
are missing how important the environment can
be in shaping traits, particularly behavioral ones.
>> So are you referring to that classic phrase, nature versus nurture?
>> Yeah, somewhat. When I was at Harvard in grad school
in the early 1930s I came up with this whole experiment that
tested the influence in the environment through conditioning. For example, I can
put a rat in this chamber, and then flash the green light.
If the rat pushes the lever, it gets food. But if
the rat pushes the lever whenever the red light is up,
it gets a mild electric shock instead. Over time, the rat
learns only to push the lever when the green light is on.
>> So you're talking about behavioral traits, where
reward and punishment play a significant role. And
this is any type of trait, right? Like
aggression or even behaviors. Like, interacting with other people.
>> That's right. Understanding the stimuli is really important
if we're going to understand the complex traits and
the hereditary and environmental components.
>> If you're interested in learning
more about conditioning and B.F. Skinner, check
out udacity's Intro to Psychology course. We'll post a link on this page.